tonight we do welcome Sharon Weinberger
she's the author of imaginary weapons a
journey through the Pentagon's
scientific underworld which is an
insightful at times quizzical look at
the questionable science and outrageous
history of behind ongoing weaponry
development in the depths of the
Department of Defense specifically to
hafnium isomer bomb advanced in theory
flawed in application she will talk
about the book and then we will as usual
open it up for questions and at that
point we do ask that you use our
audience microphone if you can get there
it does keep the talk audible and does
help out so we ask you to do that and
Sharon is the editor in chief of defense
technology international a bimonthly
editorial supplement to Aviation Week
and space technology her writing on
science and technology has also appeared
in Slate and the Washington Post
magazine which is where this book
originated in article form so thank you
very much for coming in tonight and
please help me welcome Sharon Weinberger
thanks for coming
you know since writing this book a lot
of people have asked me what motivated
me or what kind of led me to writing a
book and certainly it didn't start off
being about what the book is about which
is a nuclear isomer bomb it started off
I think much earlier from my work in
defense industry and then later writing
about the defendant defense industry and
this is a world you know that exists
around the Washington Beltway I think in
a very unique way and in many ways is
itself a scientific in a defense
underworld and so I think that the
origin of this book really goes back to
probably 1999 or 2000 when I was
preparing to leave a small defense
company in Northern Virginia whereas
working as a defense analyst and the
next week I was starting work as a
defense journalist whose son on the
other side of the fence and the head of
the company sat me down to give me sort
of his farewell spiel and you know
usually this is when people talk to you
about your future career and things that
you might accomplish and what you might
want to do and the head of this defense
company instead start talking about the
fallout shelter in his backyard
and how he was preparing for a nuclear
war and he talked about it in the way
that many in Washington might talk about
their barbecue you know how he had built
it and how he maintained it in what he
put in it and then went into an
extensive dialogue about which way winds
might blow after a nuclear weapon goes
off in Washington and how much dirt you
need over your fallout shelter anam now
we kind of carried on like this for a
little while and it was a very normal
conversation so I thought that this was
the weirdest conversation I'd ever had
and and there was something very typical
about it because these were the types of
conversations we had every day in
defense industry and it seems so normal
and then going over and writing in the
defense industry and having colleagues
there you know we would continue to run
into these very strange things you know
weapons that just never seemed they
could work or you know things just so
strange and yet they existed you know
people proposing lightening guns and
sort of solve it all weapons and you
know a lot of this book I think comes
out of dialogues with my friends and
colleagues in the defense industry that
starts with a basic question how did it
get here you know how did it happen how
do you get these ideas that are so
strange and so I began thinking that
it'd be nice to write a narrative you
know an article or book about how a
weapon becomes a weapon and particularly
about how strange weapons and strange
ideas become weapons and the problem was
I didn't know what weapon to write about
so I started off thinking I'd write
about nuclear bunker busters is some
sort of obsession and in the current
administration that you could build a
nuclear weapon to you know get deep
underground targets and you know I
couldn't really find an interesting
story around it and I was at a at a talk
in Washington in late 2003 and someone
asked about something called a hafnium
bomb and the name itself was so
intriguing I I just kind of had to find
out more about it and this book is an
outgrowth of that one question you know
how did a hafnium bomb come about so I'm
going to start off by reading just a
short passage from the book about how I
first learned about this weapon
it was on Halloween October 31st 2003
that I first learned about the
Pentagon's plans to build a frightening
new bomb not just any bomb but a weapon
so powerful it could melt human flesh
penetrate deep underground into hardened
bunkers and evaporate whole city blocks
with one fell blast it would be unlike
any bomb mankind had ever created
producing a powerful burst of gamma rays
delivering fatal doses of radiation in
just seconds it could create a powerful
fireball like a nuclear weapon spewing
radioactive material far and wide in the
hands of a suicide bomber such a weapon
could prove devastating allowing
terrorists to threaten entire cities
with just a single explosive Laden car I
would later learn that the Pentagon
believed the Russians had been looking
up at their own version of the bomb and
so too perhaps were the North Koreans
the military and official documents was
calling this new bomber revolution of
warfare comparable to the discovery of
nuclear fission and foreign journalists
were issuing dire warnings that a news
I'm arms race was on the horizon it was
a bomb so terrifying that when officials
from the Central Intelligence Agency had
followed its worldwide progress for over
a decade and the State Department's arms
control experts concerned about the
threat of a new era of proliferation
we're calling up Pentagon officials
demanding explanations and the fall of
2003 when I first learned about this
bomb the Pentagon had just assembled the
nation's top experts to look into mass
producing the critical material to be
used in it it was a material so precious
and expensive that a mere gram could
cost as much as 1 billion building the
facilities to produce the material could
run the tens of billions of dollars a
tidy sum but worthwhile perhaps if the
alternative were to allow foreign
countries to surpass the United States
and military power the most frightening
of all such a weapon once built might
not fall under any existing arms control
agreement the system of checks and
balance is meant to contain weapons of
mass destruction however flawed and
ineffective will collapse into a
meaningless pile of papers the world
could be facing a new arms race of
frightening proportions so how was it
then that the Pentagon embarked on a
quest for a new super bomb and no in the
United States seemed to notice maybe it
was because in the fall of 2003 the u.s.
national security establishment was busy
looking for non-existent weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq
and maybe it was because Congress with
little public attention was getting
ready to roll back a decade old banned
the prohibited work on new nuclear
weapons and so-called low yield weapons
or mini nukes or maybe it was because
this frightening new bomb never existed
it was in the pure sense just an
imaginary weapon as it was I only
learned about this weapon by chance
through a last-minute decision to attend
a seminar on Capitol Hill one of dozens
of such briefings that take place in
Washington every day
Stephen younger senior Pentagon weapons
scientist was making the case for why
the country needed new nuclear weapons
off the record there's a typical crowd
that showed up at talks in Washington on
nuclear weapons a mix of grim-faced
policy wonks an aging social activists a
woman identifying herself as a
psychologist raised her and to ask a
question only to launch into a ten
minute diatribe against war and violence
younger look physically pained someone
asked about so-called bunker busting
nukes nuclear weapons designed to
penetrate deep underground younger
cheered up because he liked this topic
and then a man behind me asked young
core what he thought about the hafnium
bomb younger and nuclear weapons
designer by training just chuckled as if
the question were some sort of inside
joke not only to a select few that could
really appreciate it after the talk
finished and people start shuffling for
the door I turned around to catch the
man who had asked about the bomb
couldn't help but notice that someone
had passed him an official use only a
report and he somehow possessed an air
of authority
I barely caught the name of the bomb but
I was certain I'd never heard of it
what's a hafnium bomb I asked he
squinted at me for a moment then smiled
mysteriously and said call me handing me
a card excusing himself quickly the
plain white card with Peter Zimmerman
scientific consultant I returned to my
desk in the Senate press cowering for a
few hours I forgot about the hafnium
bomb entirely and tell us about ready to
leave work for the day and spotted the
plain white card sitting precariously
close to the edge of my desk I paused
for a moment thinking about all the
things I had to do that week and then I
picked up the phone and called him the
next day to think of her coffee in the
bottom of the Russell Senate office
building Peter Zimmerman began to
explain what the hafnium bomb was like
many physicists and simmerman spoke with
his hand sketching out diagrams formulas
and equations as he spoke he leaned over
the table grab my notebook and began
tracing out the shape of the second
metastable state of hafnium 178th oblong
spending on an axis that looked like an
elongated football using stick-figure
diagrams he tried to show how this
charged up form of irregular
atomic nucleus called an isomer would
decay over time emitting its energy in
the form of gamma rays doing what
physicists call back-of-the-envelope
calculation Zimmermann explained what
made the obscure hafnium isomer so
attractive to the Pentagon it packed one
hell of a wallop one gram of the ice
material would have the same energy as
one-third of a ton of TNT
the explosive force if it could be
released would approach that of nuclear
fission I nodded my head pretending to
follow a bit of what he was describing I
didn't understand much of anything and
then it got really weird the Pentagon of
coin has a mermaid start of a project to
use this material to build a bomb far
more powerful than any conventional
explosive the notional concept he told
me was a nuclear hand grenade and the
whole thing was based on an experiment
conducted in 1982 1998 that involved a
dental x-ray machine and a scientist
from an obscure University in Texas
dental x-ray machine I asked a
secondhand dental x-ray machine he
corrected there was another issue
prominent scientists repeated the
original experiment and found nothing no
results yet the Pentagon was starting
down the path of what looked like it
would become a massive weapons project
so it's like a nuclear weapon I asked
yes he replied but it'll never work
worse yet if it did work it would in
some ways be worse than a nuclear weapon
because it could be used to create an
explosive force it would disperse highly
radioactive material far and wide
hafnium 178 had a 31-year half-life
dwarfing the radioactivity of uranium
the material used in nuclear weapons the
isomer bomb he said would be the world's
best radiological dispersal device and
how did he know it wouldn't work it's a
bit like Potter Stewart's definition of
pornography he said referring to the
Supreme Court justices famous 1973 I
know it when I see it description one
knows bad science and after a while
learns to recognize it as such that said
he had checked out the claims Zimmerman
explained that he'd served in government
a few years back he commissioned a
high-level panel of elite scientists a
secretive group called the Jason's to
look at the hafnium bomb that Jason's I
asked I'd never heard of the Jason's it
was if there was a whole underworld of
national security I knew nothing about
the Jason Zimmerman explain were a group
of secretive elite scientists who held
some of the highest security clearances
access provided them say could review
any technical matter faced in government
for hafnium the Jason's determination
was conclusive the science was dubious
and such a weapon simply wasn't feasible
hafnium couldn't be made into a bomb for
a host of scientific and technical
reasons it was too radioactive to be
around it was too expensive to produce
there was no way to get the chain
reaction needed for an explosion the
original experiment in 1998 the panel
concluded was not solid proof of
anything
in essence the jasons conclude the whole
thing didn't pass was a merman liked to
call the snicker test and other things
about the initial experiments dr.
Zimmerman is bad science
the Texas scientist former student was
disavowing the original results
Andy added there were other rumors
though unconfirmed there have been some
funny business with obtaining the
hafnium and of course there was a basic
issue with the experiment a dental x-ray
machine despite all that according to
Zimmerman the Pentagon had already
assembled a group of senior scientists
to look at ways to mass-produce the
hafnium isomer an endeavor that would
run the tens of billions of dollars one
of the scientists at the production
panel a Stanford physicist named William
Herman's felt was trying to kill the
whole thing he told me you should call
him he said remember I considered the
possibility that Zimmerman Zimmerman was
pulling my leg I tried to imagine
calling up a scientist I'd never met and
asking about a secret Pentagon nuclear
hand grenade if we're true I couldn't
imagine he'd talk about it and if it
weren't true I'd sound ridiculous there
was something about the whole idea that
seemed unbelievable
if the weapon couldn't work I asked what
difference did it make what the Pentagon
dropped up being a nuclear style bazooka
or nuclear hand grenade at some point
like dozens of other Pentagon projects
the whole thing the Pentagon would
simply give up consumer man paused and
leaned back in his chair and then gave a
philosophical reply he had a long term
view of the hafnium bomb I think that a
program like this one started will have
an enormous amount of inertia he said it
won't be a matter of someone deciding
this is just a waste of money it will
stick around for years and likely grow
in scope his concerns also went well
beyond the science then there's the
international relations aspect of it he
said do we want to advertise that we're
going to build a new nuclear type weapon
based on new physical principles what
sort of message to the center our allies
to other countries dental x-rays big
bombs and mad scientists the whole thing
sounded implausible
the Pentagon was certainly known for
pursuing some unconventional ideas but a
super bomb based on a dental x-ray by
the time we bid goodbye already knew
that have a call William Herman's felt
and that I would try to learn more about
the hafnium
I had embarked on a journey that day and
without quite knowing it I'd cross some
threshold I was entering a scientific
underworld I never knew existed this
book is an attempt to explore that fuzzy
line between military science and
official foolishness when an unusual
little experiment becomes a Pentagon
boondoggle the hafnium bomb began with
the idea of building a handheld device
with the explosive power approaching
that of a nuclear bomb it was in the
truest sense of the word an imaginary
weapon in the end all it took was a use
dental x-ray machine a few diehard
supporters some far-fetched claims of a
new arms race and the Pentagon thought
it was on its way to the next super bomb
I'm going to spend just a couple minutes
talking about then the story that
emerges from this book and the reaction
I've had to it you know I feel like this
book is about two things it's about the
kind of that the two-year journey I went
on trying to find out how that dental
x-ray machine went in 1998 to being a
full-scale you know sort of weapons
exploratory project in the Pentagon by
2003 but it also began a secondary theme
of you know what is the scientific
underworld really mean and how do we
know what is good science and what's bad
science and as a country you know what
our national security institutions
should look into and fun and so through
this two years I found everything in the
Pentagon from psychics and telepathy to
zero-point energy and claims of infinite
energy the story of the hafnium bomb
then became said of a microcosm one way
of telling a larger story of the many
many weird and fringy projects the
Pentagon gets involved in but the real
question is what when does something go
off the deep end and I don't know that
there's a good answer to that and the
case of the hafnium bomb this is really
a story about one true believer a
scientist in Texas named Carl Collins
who for 20 years had been working in
this esoteric area of nuclear isomers
these charged-up nucleus trying to make
a breakthrough that he thought would
make his name in science in the 1980s
under Ronald Reagan Star Wars
he'd been funded to work on nuclear
isomers as part of building a gamma-ray
laser a sort of theoretical concept
when Star Wars was cancelled he went on
to other projects eventually coming over
to hafnium in 1998 with what became the
famous dental x-ray experiment which
wasn't that published in a very very
prestigious journal Physical Review
Letters with the publication of his
results from the dental x-ray experiment
he immediately began to get noticed you
know everyone from the CIA to the DIA to
the State Department took notice and
eventually he got tens of millions of
dollars or the project got tens of
millions of dollars from the Pentagon
and the idea that these results could be
the basis of a nice Andhra bomb what
becomes problematic in the story of the
isomer bomb is that every single review
there were two independent
government-sponsored reviews that said
it was bunk there were counter
experiments done in the department of
energy laboratories which contradicted
the results and his own collaborators
his former student went on to say these
results couldn't be replicated and yet
the Pentagon didn't give up so this book
really traces how a group of Pentagon
officials sort of coalesced around this
very charismatic Texas scientist and
began to really hype these results and
it also talks about my own experience
dealing with this Texas scientist who in
many ways I think is a very tragic story
who really wanted to make a breakthrough
in science it never happened and the
more he came under attack really began
to strike back very personally
now the question of what makes bad
science and good science I think is
still something under review the book
talks about other strange things the
Pentagon has been involved in for
instance you know one of the very
well-known cases was during the Cold War
and up through 1995 the military
intelligence community funded psychics
the idea you know we could have people
you know tracing out new nuclear Soviet
submarines or no spot things the remote
viewing another example was $25,000 the
airforce bent on a study of telepathy
I'm sorry teleportation this is sort of
a Star Trek concept there's been
long-standing interest in concepts of
infinite energy ranging from cold fusion
to zero-point energy and after the book
was published I got along with some very
nice reaction you know a long list of
letters from former psychics current
psychics people involved in zero point
energy cold fusion and
Gradius people saying well how do you
know that our idea doesn't work have you
explored I our idea how come you've
grouped it all under fringe science and
the truth is we don't know that none of
these things work I know that the isomer
bomb was certainly flawed because I
looked at two years worth of evidence of
internal reports external reports of a
coalition a consensus of scientists who
said that the 1998 experiments were
flawed I have not looked at every study
on psychics and yes the military did a
number of studies on psychics I have not
looked at every scientific paper on
zero-point energy I don't really
understand all of the antigravity
concepts but I'm pretty sure it doesn't
come from alien technology like some of
these people believe you know we
shouldn't say it all relies on common
sense but what unites all of these ideas
is that the mainstream scientific
community rejects them the mainstream
scientific community has looked at these
results and says it doesn't meet our
standards they say either that the
results aren't good enough or they just
aren't scientific and by the way we only
study natural phenomena when it comes to
national security what I would say is if
you don't want to rely on the scientific
community if you want to fund projects
you know what are you going to rely on
the world is full of perpetual motion
machines it is full of people who have
strange ideas and if you aren't going to
rely on technical advice on scientists
and on peer review you're gonna be
funding a lot of strange things and a
lot stranger things in the isomer bomb
in terms of some of the other kind of
interesting things that I got as a
result of this is that Carl Collins the
main scientists behind these results you
know launched his own website to defend
himself in some unusual ways and kind of
began a personal vendetta in defending
his results and this was in a sense was
an extension of a lot of things that
talked about that were talked about in
this book that every time someone
criticized him it became a very very
personal campaign rather than a
scientific campaign
and that's another feature that I see in
the scientific underworld and rather
than trying to work on new results
better results a lot of people on the
edges of science simply say you don't
understand my results the other
experiments were flawed that the system
is against me the scientific community
just doesn't work right and I guess my
answer to that is what is a better
system over the past week I had just a
wonderful email conversation with a
gentleman discussed in this book and
that's Jack's or Fatih who is um a one
time mainstream physicist who I guess is
known to some he's very notorious in the
scientific world he started off in
conventional physics and I think maybe
the 1970s went off into rather
unconventional directions and wisdom
co-founder I think it was the physics
consciousness group and um I credit him
in the book as being the inventor of the
god phone he says that in fact there was
an earlier inventor of the god phone but
you know we engaged in actually what was
a wonderful dialogue this week where he
um he read the book in great detail he
said I agree I agree the isomer bomb was
a flawed idea but he said you you're not
really giving you're giving short shrift
to cold fusion and zero point energy
into psychics and so I said Jack you
know what what what what's the
alternative what is your method other
than peer review other than scientific
consensus to look at these results and
he said I'll think about it and that was
actually a really wonderful dialogue
because my my response to those on the
fringes of science and and I think a lot
of these people are well-intentioned and
that some of them may even be onto
something is that if you don't accept
scientific consensus you know please for
the rest of us suggests an alternative
and I keep waiting for that alternative
so I do hope that some of these people
on the fringes of science have something
but I think that we'll only know if they
have something if they go about their
work the old-fashioned way which is
reproducible experiments and theories
that predict you know as a whole I like
to say this book is about you know a
microcosm of a scientific underworld but
I try to address a larger theme which is
national security institutions and how
they deal with science you know the
hafnium bomb it many times is a very
very comic story you know especially if
we're dealing with you know how a dental
x-ray did or did not trigger this read
you active material but it's also a much
serious story about weapons of mass
destruction and how the Pentagon deals
with technical advice and how they
decide which things are a threat and
which things are not a threat as I like
to say the hafnium bomb is funny but
imaginary weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq are not very funny and that there's
a sincere lack of both technical
expertise I think increasingly in the
Pentagon an increasing unwillingness
among those in the Pentagon and
intelligence community to turn to
scientists I'm a lot of the characters
in this book people who were senior
scientists in in the government these
positions a lot of them no longer exist
the downsizing of the military in the
1990s I think we lost a lot of our
resident expertise and we increasingly
rely on defense contractors and outside
boards for what should be internal
advice so you know I guess what I've
learned about the I summer bomb is two
things a that we need some sort of
scientific advice we should not be
beholden to scientists but we should
call on them when we need to and the
second thing and I think this is the
thing I'm still learning and my thoughts
and it are still being revised is that
we should never ever dismiss something
out of hand as being fringe we should
never say oh that idea sounds crazy so
it must be crazy but neither do I think
the scientific community does that but
we should explore and investigate
outlandish claims for me the lesson of
September 11th was I certainly thought
that you know you know no one would be
capable and certainly not a summa bin
Laden of coordinating you know multiple
plane attacks against the United States
I would have thought that claim was
outlandish and I think it took September
11 to really change my mind on that now
that being said hijacking planes doesn't
violate the laws of physics but um we
should consider the the unlikely and
that's another lesson of the book and I
really think that the scientific
community considered the idea that an
isomer bomber sort of new nuclear weapon
was possible they considered it they
investigated it and they rejected it and
the question is why didn't the Pentagon
and don't think that's all I have to say
could you talk a little bit more about
kind of the larger policy implications
and especially as this current
administration attitude towards science
in general and the formation of policy
I'm sure there's been a lot said about
the how this administration or others
have written about how this
administration has abused and used
science to their own ends that basically
they have a policy goal and they would
like science either to press on towards
that policy goal or where it doesn't
agree with that they simply disregard it
here that there's I think a good book on
that called the Republican war on
science you know for me that's a
different issue than what I look at and
I'm careful well I think there's a very
strong argument to be made that this
administration has been very bad for
science and I think there are some
multiple examples of that I would be
cautious to say that in general on all
issues it's a Republican versus Democrat
issue you know a lot of what I described
in this book on the outsourcing of our
resident expertise and the Pentagon
happened in the 1990s not at of any
nefarious purposes but just out of the
peace dev and dividend when we were
downsizing a lot of our military
laboratories I don't think that was done
you know to get rid of scientific advice
it was just done it was sort of a
negligent byproduct of it another thing
that we've seen is a lot of the
scientific posts that were in government
you know sort of senior scientific
advisors as well as boards have
disappeared over the years and that's
something that long predates this
administration but certainly I think
that there's plenty and plenty of
examples under this administration where
it's gone even further downhill but I
guess my cautionary word would be you
know we'll have a new administration in
in 2008 one way or the other whether
it's democratic or republican and my
hope would be that they really look at
how we deal with scientific advice know
when we have things like you know
nuclear weapons or global warming that
whatever way you fall on the issue that
you'd be willing to look at what
scientific consensus means and you know
I'm even changing my mind you know what
one physicist said to me is and one of
the interesting things is when does that
scientific consensus flip like on global
warming you know what point did that
happen and what does that mean and so
those are some of the things that I
think we need to think about as we move
forward is just how in general the
government
with science I wonder if you'd modify
your statement that unusual claims
deserves to be investigated it's
certainly true that in the case of
Collins which was on its face vaguely
plausible because of the physical review
letter
government labs spent a lot of money
checking it and finding out it's
nonsense but claims of psychic powers
and things like that and the military
efficacy of Prayer and so on I think
those those need to be dismissed out of
hand I would be very unhappy of a
university or a government laboratory
we're willing to spend ten million
dollars or something to investigate
alleged psyche back and I wonder why
understand for Research Institute which
supported put off and tarred in with
their psychic claims of the sudden why
that institution still has a decent
reputation it should its reputation
should have been destroyed by its
support of the research of put often
target in the seventies you know I'm
Stanford Research Institute which I now
believe is colleges si s RI
internationals have spinoff of Stanford
and it is a very very reputable
reputable Rd Research Center which has
done some it's done some very very usual
typical good things they've also been
out on the fringes one example was how
put off and Russell Targ who were under
contract to investigate psychic
phenomena for the military I think and
that was in the 1980s up through the
1990s I forget the years exactly you
know I haven't investigated it in detail
how put off the on the main guy in this
program just emailed me the other day to
ask me to look at some of his papers and
I will do that you know I think one of
the things you bring up is um you know
what should science investigate and I do
I do agree that the starting point is
science is based on natural phenomenon
so you know questions of whether science
should investigate prayer you know does
prayer help help it's I think that falls
into the unnatural phenomena and I think
that the scientific community probably
would not find it worth their money or
their time to investigate it you know
there are certainly some theories out
there you know involving Quantic how
quantum mechanics can imply can explain
psychic phenomena
you know where does this fall should
scientists being investigating it you
know where there's a scientific theory I
guess I would kind of say you know if
some scientists want to do it and they
can find people to support it that
aren't a part of our national security
institutions go for it um maybe there's
something there the question is when
does it rise to the standard of national
security because again as I said the
world is full of strange and wonderful
things that if true could be worth
investing in you know what's interesting
is I've spent a lot of time over the
past two years you know spending time
with ColdFusion s and you know all sorts
of people on the fringes and and they
always say a couple million more dollars
look at the results I have and this was
certainly wet on how putt-off argued and
those of his colleagues so we had these
great results for psychics and you know
my response is well you couldn't
convince the scientific community I mean
there's sort of the old standard you
know if you're a psychic why aren't you
rich you've won the lottery and there's
always an explanation for why they
haven't well you know it's the
laboratory conditions it's very hard to
replicate it well okay but at the end of
the day you know science is full of
competing claims and scientists are
going to make decisions about which ones
they want to spend their careers
investing it in in my problem with the
people who investigate psychics is they
always had a reason for why maybe the
laboratory conditions weren't really
analogous to the real world and you know
all I can say is from what I've seen
although I need to read the articles in
greater detail is they clearly weren't
getting results that um really stopped
the world and benefited our national
security institutions just wondering
isn't the Jason Group a good check on
bizarre projects and are there examples
of the Pentagon going forward excuse me
with a project that they've rejected as
bad science um just for a little bit of
background the Jason's are this group
that have been around I think since
approximately 1960 I forget their exact
date of inception and these are
scientists with outside affiliations
typically the majority of them are
academics there's about 55 to 60 at one
time lots of Nobel Prize winners
and they've been supported by the
Pentagon since about 1960 to do Studies
on you know whatever government agencies
choose to do it on they started off
doing a lot on ballistic missile defense
nuclear weapons have moved into lots of
areas they looked at the hafnium bomb
you know there's actually a great book
out by an Finkbeiner on the history of
the Jason's which came out just a few
months ago that talks in great detail
about their origins and one of the
hardest things I think that an had was
you know what is the result of adjacent
study because the Jason's themselves
don't necessarily know there's been
examples that I can think of certainly
where the Jason's have been again
something and it goes on probably the
hafnium bomb is one such example and the
question is what role have the Jason's
historically played in national security
and I think who you speak to you get a
different version and the hafnium bomb
sort of episode Peter Zimmerman who is
one of the chief enemies of this idea
hired the Jason's to look at it and
certainly he was hiring them with the
idea is they're gonna show how stupid of
idea it is and they did but that said
what the Jason's did was very very
independent and very very well reasoned
and argued so I think what it says is a
lot of times Jason's are hired either to
confirm an idea as good or to debunk an
idea that people think is bad what
effect they've had is very very hard to
measure because historically the
sponsors have not wanted to talk about
that the Jason's themselves say I think
from Anne's book that their greatest
rule has been said of the lemon test
when an idea is really really bad you've
done some you know along with the
hafnium bomb they looked at them
neutrinos you know and a bunch of sort
of you know bad
no there's like bad science but science
with them some sort of your weird
applications that wasn't going to work
out so they what impact they've had
historically I think that's still
history in the making
Parsa part of this because I know a
number of people on Jason the thing that
I find most disturbing is how the
military selectively rejects
constructive criticism whether it's SDI
or things related that or you can call
it fusion and yet funding still goes on
and I guess after a while one becomes
jaded and I was curious you seem to have
implied that while you were working in
the defense industry you had a much more
benign view of what objective criticism
is and then when you became a journalist
you began to see a different perspective
and I'm just a little surprised at that
because there are many examples that
yeah it make you quite skeptical even if
you're on working for the defense it's
interesting being on both sides of it
because I think both sides are very
jaded those of us who write about the
defense industry are I think really
jaded because you know they're these
moments where we turn to our colleagues
and be like well didn't we just hear
this wasn't the f-22 over budget a year
ago and didn't missile defense you know
have it's messy it you begin to hear the
same things over and over and over again
and so maybe the difference on the
defense industry side is you hear that
same element of being jaded where I'm
you know company I had worked for did a
lot on countermeasures of missile
defense back in the 1980s under under
Star Wars and you know I remember some
when the companies saying oh yeah we
lost our contract is the last thing they
ever want to hear about missile defense
or countermeasures and here we were
doing the analysis on countermeasures
but you know the differences with
defense industry is this is their
business you know they have to go on and
earn money because that's what their
shareholders want that's what the
employees want so it's different
motivations but it's the same idea of
being jaded that you see the same
mistakes being repeated you see the same
advice being rejected and and nothing
ever changes and that's and I think that
the difference between what I do on a
daily basis in this book and some of the
response I've gotten was you know what
we report on a daily basis is you know
twenty billion dollars thirty billion
dollars in the numbers
staggering you know a space satellite
program being you know 30 billion over
budget and so people would say well an
isomer bomb or psychics or cold fusion
or whatever the program does your that's
only two million dollars twenty million
dollars thirty million dollars and I
become really insulted because maybe
it's from seeing the twenty billion
dollars and I still say you know that's
taxpayer money you know that ain't free
and and also what perspective is is that
satellite programs run thirty billion
dollars over budget but science and
basic science and this is something that
was new to me operates on a completely
different perspective I once asked a
scientist you know how much would a am a
Nobel Prize winner in physics get for
his lab or her lab you know just on
average and you know obviously the
numbers vary but I was told you know one
million dollars a year is a very
respectable budget so now you talk about
a scientist as I described in this book
who repeatedly got bad peer reviews was
repeatedly you know really debunked by
the scientific community and has gotten
twenty million dollars thirty million
dollars funded at this you know I call
this the cost of lost opportunities you
know you can say it's only twenty or
thirty million dollars but imagine you
know the work that Charles Townes did on
the maze or the precursor to the laser
that wasn't a lot of money either
imagine if rather than funding Charles
Townes we had funded the guy who said
you know I have a lightning gun based on
a Tesla coil and it can go across the
room and revolutionize warfare and I've
spoken with some of these people and
they're very sincere and I guess I would
say well you know there should be a
standard for how we decide what to
invest in and the only standard I've
seen that really works seem to be you
know some form of peer review and the
scientific community looking at these
things
hi Sharon hi more of a general question
amid some of the recent controversy of
the New York Times and other
publications publicizing some classified
programs that the Bush administration
has used in the war on terrorism I was
just wondering what extent if any you
had in regards to classified or
sensitive sensitive information and
doing the research for this book and has
the research for this book and the
recent controversies with the New York
Times and the administration that
historical tension between the
journalism field and the government has
your research done anything to affect
those attitudes yeah one of the things
that I think made that the history of
the isomer bomber rideable was because
it was still at the level of basic
science a lot of things you know that
this book about you know the current
missile defense would not have been able
to be written because too much of it
would have been classified but because
the the controversy over the isomer bomb
was still at the level of basic physics
and pretty much none of it was
classified so people were able to speak
to me about it - give me documents but
already I saw that you know government
officials were marking you know emails
official use only sort of a meaningless
classification just to make sure it
didn't get out to the press and towards
the end of the book the the program
official and the Pentagon responsible
for it started to say well we're not
going to talk about future experiments
because you have big national security
implications you know there are I'm sure
as you know many good reasons for things
to be classified I see too much of
classification used to hide questionable
science programs that are over budget
programs that people don't want to
discuss weapons that might be
embarrassing so I see examples of that I
think as many and this is I'm not alone
in saying this way too many things are
classified in Clemmy things should be
classified to protect national security
not to protect yourself from
embarrassment and and that really is the
gold standard you know my concern about
the isomer bomb and a lot of people have
raised this before me is that you know
it could be continuing on as part of a
black or classified program you know
hidden away from scientific review that
was certainly the case of support for
you know the CIA and dia in their
research into psychics it was classified
until 1995 and in fact out after the
book came out I've been engaged in a
friendly email dialogue with one of the
military officials who was behind it and
he said well you don't understand you
know psychics were used operationally by
the military but a lot of that still
classified so if you only knew what they
really did you would realize that
psychics were great and not you know how
do you how do you answer that I don't
know I'm still trying to think about
that
wondered if you could talk a little bit
about some of the scientists that you
met it sounds like you've talked to some
people who are have these ideas that
they just are never gonna give up on it
so I wonder if after talking to them and
interviewing them and and kind of
knowing that it's really on the fringe
and it's bunk how what do you think I
mean are they just gonna cling to these
ideas until their dying breath and pray
that they get funded or what what would
you hope for those people and what do
you think will happen for them in the
future yeah III that's a really
wonderful question and the case of Carl
Collins the scientists in this book a
lot of people thought that he just went
perhaps over the edge that you know you
know he'd had questionable results in
the past and people had really
questioned whether he was doing
experiments in the right way but at
least he was you know he was publishing
and mainstream scientific journals he
was going to conferences so say what you
will he was operating in the realms of
the scientific community and that slowly
after 1998 as his results came under
more and more scrutiny he started you
know sending out very very personal
email attacks against other scientists
certainly since the book coming out has
come out I've seen this as well and so I
think what you see you know I think
there's a larger phenomenon at work here
there's been something described as
pathological science where a scientist
kind of comes across an experimental
result that ends up being wrong as it's
repeated by other people it doesn't work
but they cling on to their experiment
and they say other scientists just don't
understand it they didn't do the
experiment right and in some cases
they're right and they come up with
better results in the scientific
community says okay but in other cases
like with the isomer bomb that doesn't
the case and yet the scientists never
give up you know cold fusion is one of
these areas that I have a great deal of
personal sympathy for you know there you
have you know some 200 scientists who
have continued to try to say that they
reproduced the results that went back to
1989 when two chemists claimed to have
generated room-temperature fusion which
if true would have potentially been on a
limited source of energy or nearly
unlimited so you still have a lot of
scientists who work in this area and
they claim they have results and
that that other people aren't looking at
them and I've spent a lot of time with
these scientists and with others you
know some of the ones and other fringe
areas and you know on one hand their
plate seems so sympathetic because they
keep at it and they have results but
when you kind of extend and really look
at their results and wonder you know
what what is it that makes them keep at
it and what is it that makes others
reject it and what you really say is
they have experimental results that are
not being reproduced by the scientific
community at large and why do they do it
this isn't thing that intrigues me I I
don't know you know I spent over the
past two years you know with them you
know I spent two days speaking with a a
doctor in New Jersey who claimed that
you know the universe was governed by
waves and he had this completely unique
idea that related to waves the universe
string theory cold fusion and medical
diagnosis and then I you know I spent a
couple days speaking with him and and a
friend of his who supporters result in
trying to understand you what what is it
that makes someone go off into these
outer areas and I don't have the answer
to that you know Bob Park who's at the
University of Maryland has made sort of
a career out of debunking what he calls
voodoo science says that these are
people who wish the world were some
other way than what it is and I think
that's part of it but I think there's a
something more personal at work there
you know sort of our inability to see
our own failures I don't know I don't
have the answer there I keep wondering
and keep looking what makes people
believe in certain things I don't know
I'm gonna speak for just a second about
kind of the what what happens at the end
of this book instead of the ending
history and one of the things was was
that I wrote an article for The
Washington Post magazine on this in 2004
which shortly thereafter Congress came
in and said okay we've had enough of the
isomer Bob you know maybe you could move
on to something else and they zeroed out
the funding and in the same year they
did that the Energy Committee came in
and added five million dollars per
isomer in isotope production and so uh
you know I like to say that bad ideas
never die in the Pentagon they just sort
of live on and that's the thing you know
these ideas if you look at something
like you know lasers or missile defense
these ideas just never ever go away and
that's one of the lessons I'm just gonna
read a little bit of the epilogue it
must have been a stunning sight
reflected off a guards flashlight the
shiny metal cast back an eerie silvery
glow
it was Saturday in the sleepy border
town in Bulgaria when the Border Patrol
stopped a car holding three Romanians at
a Bulgarian driver the group was
preparing across the friendship [ __ ]
which links to countries whose relations
have never been all that friendly a
routine check of the car turned up an
unusual find over three kilograms of
pure hafnium one of the border guards
think as they search the driver and spa
the hafnium metal tucked under his
jacket perhaps they know had no idea
what the lump of mystery metal was did
they instinctively reach out to touch
the metallic object or they hesitate
worried that it might be some dangerous
radioactive substance how'd they even
know to search the driver did someone
tipped them off the Bulgarian seemed
almost in awe of the precious metal
slick and shiny even its unrefined form
anxious to advertise to the world our
diligent checkpoints Bulgarian police
have arrested four men trying to smuggle
into Romania substance scientists say
that can be used to make powerful
explosives or dirty bombs reuters
reported in September of 2005 it's a
very rare element very beautiful and
extremely expensive marina Nizam ska of
Bulgaria's Nuclear Regulatory Agency
later told AFP it can be used as a
material for rockets and even for a bomb
she said according to the Reuters report
the hafnium capture turned out to be
good publicity for the upwardly mobile
Balkan country whose porous borders have
often proved a convenient transit point
for illegal goods
Bulgaria thought smuggling of nuclear
material announced one headline as
report to the capture spread over the
International wires the Bulgarian
authorities even went as far as to call
special press conference to explain the
great importance of the intercept for
Bulgaria's national security like the
Czech Republic's desperate attempts to
impress the West with his reports never
a verified of 9/11 mastermind Mohamed
Atta's visit to Prague there was a ring
of self-promotion in the Bulgarian
government's jubilant announcement of
captured hafnium what was even more
concerning perhaps was that the
subsequent claims made the various news
reports at the Hathi and was destined
for the Middle East probably no one was
involved probably no one involved knew
fair quite got the irony that hafnium
was travelling back to Romania the
country where some might argue the
isomer bomb was first born but in the
spirit of grandiose claims one of
Scotland's leading newspapers The Sunday
Herald did run a full article of sir in
the hafnium capture was tied to Iran's
nuclear weapons program The Sunday
Herald has learned from Armenian sources
that an Arab dominated Bucharest media
was the intermediary in the hafnium deal
and the sources could not give the
intended final destination of the
consignment but the working hypothesis
of Balkan police forces is that is
linked to Iran's nuclear quest and then
again there are always al-qaeda armours
keen to buy dirty bomb materials shortly
after the seizure Romanian journalists
contacted Peter Zimmermann by then a
professor at King's College in London to
ask for his thoughts in the recent
events visions of hafnium bombs must
have clouded the journalists head since
the hafnium size was regular ground
state hafnium the silvery-gray non
radioactive metal and not the hafnium
isomer Zimmermann pointed out that it
likely posed no military threat at least
not as a weapon even if it were hafnium
isomer couldn't be used as a bombing
noted going on to reprise briefly the
scientific debate over isomer triggering
as for what threat if any regular old
happen in might pose Zimmerman suggested
one possible danger if dropped from a
couple meters onto your foot a three
kilogram of hafnium could cause injuries
um you know the Hackney Bob Segar took
place in September 2005 and I was
finishing up the book and it was the
same month at the United Nations nuclear
body under pressure for the United
States declared Iran to be non-compliant
with this non-proliferation obligations
so you know I asked like to ask me what
difference does it make and it makes all
the difference you know we talked about
you know the yellowcake you know and the
natori sale of yellowcake allegedly to
iraq and how you know ludicrous the
original document was well you know
hafnium turned out to be pretty
ludicrous and these things do creep
their way up the national security
institutions so while the - bomb is
really a story in microcosm I think and
I hope it points out to a larger concern
within the Pentagon and the intelligence
community that you know these things
really are rocket science and yeah we
shouldn't be beholding to scientist they
don't have the answers to everything you
know I remember that the jasons are
often criticized as being arrogant and
you know they don't review well new
areas of science and you know peer
review is flawed and the scientific
community is conservative and all I can
say is I'm sure that all those things
have elements of truth and those within
the scientific community are often very
critical of peer review they say that
scientists are way too ready to on
criticize proposals that contradict
their own results or could be
competitive with their funding they want
to fund their colleagues and you know
that's human nature but I I guess that
the question is always you know what
what is the alternative because what
I've seen over the past two years is
that the world is filled with a lot of
very very strange claims you know waves
that rule the universe and cold fusion
and zero point energy and psychics and
anti-gravity devices and isomer bombs
and my email just gets overloaded with
these claims and you know scientists are
very very busy people I mean I'm busy
and I spend a lot of time on this but
you know you only have so much time and
energy to investigate things and so you
need you know and money is not free it
doesn't grow on trees so you need a
method or a way of investigating these
things and I guess the counterpoint is
that I think the science and technology
base in the country is suffering from a
lack of funding and basic research and
that you know when these dollars are
tight and when there's not a lot of
money to go around you want to be twice
as careful that your funding the right
things so you know if you want to treat
you know your science and technology
base like gloss
Vegas and that you know you can have
high risk high payoff there's a lot of
perpetual motion machines out there you
can fund but if you want to contribute
to the Science and Technology basis of
the country then you should probably
have a method to the madness and the
only method that anyone has ever been
able to propose to me that makes any
sort of sense is scientific review and
scientific consensus I think there's
room in there for funding things that
are on the far reaches of science but
even then you know what is it going to
be is it going to be the isomer bomb is
it going to be zero-point energy will it
be cold fusion will it be anti-gravity
if you want to do that that again at
least have a method to that and you know
I'm still waiting for someone to propose
something there